professional skateboarder Dylan reader  died on Wednesday at age 28 of  complications from leukemia  according to Transworld Skateboarding  Dylan grew up in Westminster California  and had been skating since the age of 9  he also took on modeling gigs posing  with Cara Delevingne for DKNY z' spring  2014 campaign Cara shared this photo on  Instagram writing one of the kindest  most down - down incredible human beings  I have ever encountered  you will be so missed by so many people  fellow pro skater Tony Hawk shared this  video tribute to Dylan writing thank you  for making skateboarding so much better  while you were here Dylan skating like  this can't be taught it is a product of  passion dedication and innate style  Dylan reader had all that and more do  and impossible in his honor today while  wishing you could do it like this